please welcome the recipient of two Best
Actress Oscars ms Jodie Foster
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the writer is in the position of
creating world's people conflicts
resolutions romance and laughter in a
way it's a little a little bit like
being a deity okay in a word the writers
God that's why so many studio executives
in this town or agnostics I know for the
best screenplay based on material
previously produced or published the
deities are Arthur Miller for the
screenplay of his stage play The
Crucible Anthony Minghella for the
English Patient based on the novel of
Michael and achi Kenneth Branagh for his
adaptation of Shakespeare's Hamlet Billy
Bob Thornton for Slingblade from zone
play John Hodge a train spotter based on
Irvine Welsh's novel and the Oscar goes
to Billy Bob Thornton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh whoa
lord have mercy I know all you guys my
mom my wife my buddy Dwight over here my
little boys Willie and Harry my brothers
John and Jimmy Harvey Weinstein Bob
Weinstein god bless them
Larry meistrich at the shooting gallery
Miss Elizabeth Taylor and gosh and
Mick's ballerina it's a private joke I
said I'd say it anyway this is a
terrific honor and you know this is the
big one and what can you say to the
Academy all you people who supported
everything this year not just this and a
bunch of great actors and crew people in
this movie god bless you all Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that man has some booths said that he's
officially one of God's fit in many
faces the late screenwriter Dorothy
Parker once said that the two most
beautiful words in the English language
are check enclosed and well what she
might have added is that the two most
challenging words to a screenwriter are
fade in and among those who've met that
challenge are these nominees for
screenplays written directly for the
screen Ethan Coen and Joel Coen for
Fargo Cameron Crowe for Jerry Maguire
John Sayles for lone star Mike leave for
secrets and lies Jan Sardi and Scott
Hicks for shine and the Oscar goes to
Ethan and Joel Coen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I'd like to thank mikaël kun at
Polygram and Tim Bevan and Eric Foner
working title everyone at working title
for reading the script and making it
into a movie I'd like to thank everyone
who worked on the movie everyone over at
Mary's ophrys house I guess this woky
goes up and mostly I'd like to thank
Francis without whom the part wouldn't
have been written we would committee
would have been made and we wouldn't be
standing here like to thank those people
Roger Deakins and John Cameron as well
everybody else who worked on the movie
and I'd also like to congratulate the
other nominees in this category and
Billy Bob the other nominees in that
category as well I really as nice
company thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
last year's best actor and actress
Nicolas Cage and Susan Sarandon when we
return with more of the Oscars